[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir rien dans
les mains rien dans les poches et même
pas peur nous sommes les boniments terre
salut voila voila on va se régaler alors
bon nous on nous a dit on vous invite à
la hâte et dicks alors on s'est dit mais
pourquoi nous oui parce qu'on va faire
on sauve pas des gens on comble pas le
cancer
ouais c'est ça je moi je me suis le seul
truc que je vois c'est que duch y est la
preuve que l'ubs et risation ça marche
parce que sans moi il aurait jamais pu
travailler ailleurs
tout à fait donc je me dis je serais
resté au fond de la mer alors que la
regardent et disent épanouis le il bouge
il est libre voilà et donc
l'improvisation on peut la voir sur
différents modes on peut dire c'est un
truc de branleurs voilà c'est ça ou
alors on peut se dire mais
l'improvisation finalement est-ce que ça
sert pas le propos de cette tedx est-ce
que moi quand j'ai vu la tedx que j'ai
dit c'est quoi c'est un truc pour
sparadrap voilà oui la croix en europe
mais non alors on a vu que c'était osé
poser les actes alors si finalement oui
aux rôles s'est dit les actes finalement
c'est l'improvisation c'est osé parce
que finalement l'improvisation c'est
quoi c'est ne pas réfléchir parce que si
on réfléchit ça ça mange un oui voilà ça
t'arrange déjà mais si on réfléchit on
va pas faire le chauffeur
on va dire est-ce que ça c'est bien si
je dis ça que ahola regarde y'a là voilà
moi je vois ça je m'en vais voilà donc
en fait il faut le principe c'est pas
réfléchir c'est pas réfléchir on se
bloque
le cerveau c'est ça ouais voilà alors on
s'est dit paul illustrer ce qu'on va
faire ce qu'on m'a dit lustres et c'est
le mieux pour l'illustrer on va dire
tiens quelqu'un va nous donner un mot
comme ça et nous très rapidement mais
très rapidement à oser voir exactement
on va passer à l'acte directement sans
réfléchir et dans la bienveillance tout
à fait un
voilà on va sortir de nos placards
intérieur voir si je pouvais alors on va
faire ça deux trois fois et puis après
on essaiera de construire une
improvisation un peu plus construit
construite c'est le cas de le dire
c'est d'ailleurs on a osé
on a osé alors un lotisseur comme ça le
violon par exemple violent on réfléchit
pas on le dit long ray par exemple
alors j'ai répété toute la journée
mais je reste sur du mit vous restez sur
du mit c'est pour ça que je vous ai mis
en prison parce que bon on était parti
sur sa au début adacore le jeu long oui
oui mais vous me l'avez accordé je suis
le seul dans le lb à pouvoir bénéficier
des instruments et je vous remercie
monsieur le directeur des 4 as bon ouais
ouais c
ça booste
[Applaudissements]
ça vaut ce que ça vaut imaginer qu'on
ait réfléchi à ce sketch on l'aurait
jamais fait absolument on serait même
pas venu mais vous rendez kolarov on n'a
pas bloqué le cerveau on avait su on
aurait dû peut-être oui ou non on va
faire un autre exemple pour voir ce que
le violon bon c'était omar est un
appareil à l'autre mot amour l amour par
exemple madame oui madame lorsque je
vous vie ce soir chelsea du vieux
français
oui ces vieux français ne rapporte rien
mais bon au caire et jacques lorsque je
vous dis instantanément je tombé en
pâmoison devant vous madame pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas renvoyer le pigeon que
je vous ai envoyés et par exemple sais
pas
[Applaudissements]
là on arrête pourquoi on arrête sur une
vanne eu un truc ni le punch lines a
offert et parce qu'un pigeon mort
confère aucune nuit ouais ça ça fait
peur à tout le monde
qu'est ce qu'on demande à un autre
moment ça comment sardines
on vient de faire un nom sardines ta
phrase sourdine s'ils savaient bien
sardines ou sun youth alors vous ne
pourriez pas travailler avec
l'astrophysicien ont saisi gueule pas
nous regarder nous son projet comptant
des proches des corps vous savez quand
je vois non à quoi
10h10 laissé autant pied des sardines
foutaise
je n'avais jamais vu mais pas du tout
moment ça veut dire qu'elle ne soit peu
près des coups de chaud de prédécoupe
demander pourquoi vous me faites comme
ça j'essaie de comprendre
l'osq lorsqu'elles sont au beau milieu
de l'océan
il ne faut pas elle ne choque pas mais
non parce qu'elles sont des tumeurs
adhérents qu'un bon mais ça c'est autre
chose mais là elles sont bon dieu j'ai
une envie folle de jouer du violon au
temps où jouer du violon
[Musique]
c
c'est pas pour la performance c'est
vraiment pour adhérer aux propos qui
nous est proposé à la en fait s'il faut
pas avoir de cerveau en fait non non non
c'est ça le principe et surtout pas à
pas se limiter
démarrée direct qu'il arrive
de toute façon il arrive qu'il arrive
1 voilà on va faire on va faire une
petite expérience
on va faire une improvisation maintenant
un peu plus structuré vous avez écrit
pour la plupart des des phrases je crois
alors ce qu'on va faire ducci c'est
qu'on va prendre 3 3 p'tits papiers on
les met dans les poches accord et le
principe c'est que au sein de la
brumisation au fur et à mesure on va
devoir tirer un petit papier et on va
devoir lire la voie à ce que vous avez
écrit dans le cône elle intègre et voilà
il faut l'intégrer à ça ça aussi c'est
sylvain sont dosés parce que parfois on
les voit un c'est parce qu'ils ont c'est
pascal parce que parfois on prévoit dans
sa tête et tu les choses ne se passent
pas de la même façon il faut s'adapter
ouais c'est ça on va se régaler tout à
fait voilà un trois pas plus alors on
les a pas sélectionné on va voir ce
qu'il ya j'espère que ça a été bien
écrit c'est l'amour scientifique
alors là on peut démarrer sur un autre
score à peine thèmes d'improvisation un
mot une phrase quelque chose qui vous
passe par la tête alesi peinture
peinture la peinture un statut la
peinture la peinture du démarrage
c'est trop tard non non n'exagérez pas
on a dit qu'on font passer à l'acte mais
on n'est pas fou non plus un tiralo ne
bougeait pas mais bougez pas vous êtes
est très bien comme ça je suis fatigué m
j'essaie je sais que je vais vous est
fatigué mais vous avez la posture du
corps à est magnifique
ainsi au corail il vit de l'intérieur
mais ne bougent pas de l'extérieur
depuis ce matin 6 heures je cherche à la
même place c'est tout à fait beau hélas
vous incarnez c'est que j'ai recréé dans
ma peinture et vous comprenez gris m là
vous êtes en train de faire et quoi vous
êtes en train de montrer vos doigts
comme ça vaudois pointe vers l'univers
ici ils sont ouverts et d'autres
planètes d'autres vies alors que dès
hier vous êtes rattaché à la racine qui
vous tient voyez je crois tout à fait
vous êtes entre l'extérieur la planète
et vous attendre la racine qui vous
rattache à votre condition humaine
mais ce n'était pas ce qui était convenu
m si je puis me permettre de manquer ce
qui était convenu le losc je suis je
peux me bien sûr salage aura tout le
monde lorsque je suis venu vous voir
eh bien je vais je voulais être votre
disciples je voulais apprendre c'est
pour ça que je suis venu toquer à votre
porte
tu aimais bien l'un des plus grands
peintres dont zaz est tout à fait je me
rappelle très bien lorsque je vous ai
vus pour la première fois vous m'avez
regarder dans les yeux et vous m'avez
dit le jeune disciple vous m'avez dit le
bon le bien et le beau
[Applaudissements]
ça tombait bien ça veut dire que je suis
con et leur bilan je suis vous voyez
c'est mon âme d'artiste qui parlent même
que c'est pas moi qui l'ait dit le bon
le bien et le bonheur je me suis dit
qu'il fallait apprendre mais c'est elle
dit social vie tout est déjà appris là
dedans mais bien sûr à travers ces trois
mots le bon le bien et le beau il ya là
la nature humaine mais je n'ai pas
compris ce sens là je me suis dit que
vous aviez tout m'apprendre comment
est-ce qu'on mélange des couleurs
comment est ce qu'on fait glisser des
pinceaux sur la toile je pensais que
vous n'avez pas l'apprendre vous le
savez c'est là en vous regardant je vous
le dit tout de go m pierre qui roule
n'amasse pas mousse mais moi je suis pas
venu pour la sculpture
ça n'a rien à voir imaginez que vous
soyez ou une pierre ou le piège vous
roulez vous voulez dans ce qui est
l'état de la vie si vous la masse et de
la mousse vous perdez du temps mon dieu
je comprends vous comprenez je compte
vous devenez comme le corail
sam hamad celle de l'allemand essayait
de mettre un placard quelque part oui je
sais vous comprenez alors je ne serai
jamais bien mousseux sequans la mousse
c'est l'humilité qui fait naître la
végétation et dans la statistique
tout à l'heure vous vous êtes plaint de
la statistique j'ai fait exprès de me
rendre statique pendant des heures
pourquoi à l'intérieur de vous même
vouloir sortir quelque chose d'une
question posée m lagaize de comment j'ai
dit allez on
depuis je ne comprends pas
qu'est-ce que nous sommes au son de la
mousse de lait nous sommes un peu de
mousse dans l'univers vous savez il ya
encore deux chacun il faudrait peut-être
accélérer un peu mon dieu mais alors si
j'ai tout sans moi aussi l'âme d'artiste
qui bat au fond de mon coeur est déjà
une et rentrer en possession de mon adn
alors ça veut dire que je ne peux je
n'ai pas besoin de prendre de court vous
n'avez pas cessé que j'aimais tout vous
dire
hélas italienne lassé d'ailleurs que
j'aimais tout vous dire mais alors je
vais retourner à l'université d'être et
je veux dire je vais aller devant les
amphis de tous ces étudiants qui perdent
leur temps et je les regardais dans les
yeux et je te la mort et aux efforts au
maître de conférence et à tous mes amis
du dian les promesses n'engagent que
ceux qui les écoutent oui ça c'est très
bon oui ça c'est très bon un bon vieux
film vient une envie rep réseau n'est
payé renvoyer la couleur la cour elle
c'est la vie
les idiots mais allez-y une mouche cela
un petit caillou y est ré à présent je
peux mourir maintenant il reste deux
matchs avant de mourir je veux que tout
le monde sache que sur la pierre tombale
il sera écrit ceci ribbon ismaël in the
sign language
mais non je suis je suis russe italien
mais mon parent a été anglaise mais
alors
alors quoi lorsque vous venez de dire là
ce qui doit être gravé sur la pierre
tombale
tout le monde sourit dans le même
langage le sourire est universel la
couleur est universel
la mousse est uni gaza l a9 la can est
universel le corail est universel on
dieu vous êtes à nouveau bien veillant
au mais je suis votre égal j'ai appris
en yo-yo plus que je n'ai appris en
trois ans d'études
alors posez moi la question dites moi ce
que vous avez sur le coeur je vais vous
le dire n'être car c'est des questions
ce que j'ai sur le club el khabar haut
de neuf mois à rodez le mont houy pas
tarder jusqu'à 40 de tarot depuis le
début et maintenant que j'ai votre
confiance et que vous m'avez adoubé par
les giacomo savez bien 18 minutes qu'on
est là je vous le dis dans les yeux m
tu es déjà ce que tu cherches à
l'extérieur
[Applaudissements]
je préfère vous laisser l'attendait
bon je sais que ça tout ça vous touche m
soit mais personne ne m'a dit d'aussi
belles paroles jamais venu comme ça je
n'en suis pas responsable vous savez
comment ça rentre ça sort giacobbo vous
avez réalisé réveillé en moi des
émotions primaires c'est vrai comme les
couverts pour ico mais d'abord parce que
vous avez dit ça je me suis revu ce jour
là avec ma mère lorsqu'elle me donnait
son sein bienveillant 1st énorme
giacobbo je suivais de mes yeux je le
suivais à la recherche du téton je leurs
civettes chien qu'on est dans l'axé
bon je n'ai plus d'accès giacomo je suis
désaxé totalement et lorsque je suivais
ce saint saint omer c'est l'outil ton
identique
ma mère a posé sa main sur mon coeur que
disait m et elle m'a dit une chose aussi
belle que vous me dites à présent elle
m'a dit la vie est belle
merci merci
[Applaudissements]